CORK NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM. SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
COPULA BARRICADE HIM BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRIAN
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES JUNE
CHOI COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM
DALY DALY DAVIES FLORA FONG
FRIEDMAN APRIL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GRAY. GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY.
BLACKY LEE LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MULLIN SUCI THIS AREA
WHEN O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORP UGH SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE REBAJAS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH
STONE. D. CALAVERAS THE APPROVED
WA VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY. TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
DAZE PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR
KHAN IMAM YASIR. IN THE NAME OF
GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. ALL POWERFUL GOD. MAY
WE PROVE OURSELVES RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE TASK YOU SET BEFORE US
TODAY AS YOUR SERVANTS. GIVE US
THE STRENGTH TO PERSEVERE AND
DOING GOOD AND FORBID EVIL. MY
GREAT WORK OF JUSTICE RISE FROM
US- DROWNED OUT ALL NEGATIVITY
AND DISCONTENT. LET US LIVE AS
FREE PEOPLE NEVER SING OUR
FREEDOM AS A PRETEXT FOR EVIL.
RATHER AS SERVANTS OF GOD MAY WE
HONOR ALL PEOPLE. LOVE THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE AND FEAR
ONLY YOU ARE IN. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN DR WEBER
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE DR
WEBER PLEASE JOIN ME AND I
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. THANK
YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY SCHIRMER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY FEBRUARY THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY TO THE CINEMATIC NINETY
ON THE OUT OF FOCUS FOR AND MORE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SEVENTY EIGHT
THIS PROVIDING CHEAP
LEXICOGRAPHER DESK. CLERK DAVID
BOWMAN READING WILL CALL THE
ROLL CALL. IS MOVES. AND MR
GALLAGHER SECONDS AT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS
HAVE PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RICHARD BLUM.
FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRANK BIGELOW. A MEDICAL
LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH. WE
ARE MOVING TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
AND. THIS RACE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS CARILLO AND
VOEPEL TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
MEMBERS MEMBERS. WE HAVE
GUESTS WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY PLEASE RECORD TENSION TO
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER MR
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FROM MY DESK IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER MEMBERS AND- ONCE AGAIN
WE ARE RECOGNIZING. SOME OF OUR
AMAZING STAFF WHO ARE RETIRING-
YOU KNOW FROM US AFTER MANY
YEARS OF DEDICATED SERVICE TO
THE STATE AND SO TODAY WE ARE
RECOGNIZING CAROLINE KNEELAND-
WHO IS RETIRING FROM OUR-
REPUBLICAN POLICY COCKETT SHOP-
CAROLINE IS. HAS TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS OF DEDICATED SERVICE TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SHE
JOINED OUR REPUBLICAN POLICY
TEAM IN TWENTY NINETEEN AS A
CONSULTANT ON BUDGET SUB TO- SO
FOR MY COLLEAGUES THAT HAVE
SERVED ON THE BUDGET SUB YOU
SEEN CAROLINE SHE'S BEEN A VITAL
PART OF OUR STAFF. AND HER
BACKGROUND AND EXPERTISE- HAS
TRULY BEEN INVALUABLE TO ALL OF
US ON THE COMMITTEE. WE COULD
NOT DO THIS JOB WITHOUT GOOD
STAFF. BEHIND THE SCENES AND I
CAN TRULY SAY THAT CAROLINE. HAS
BEEN ONE OF THE BEST AND WILL BE
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE'RE GOING TO
REPLACE YOUR HONESTLY. I CAN I
CAN TELL YOU BEING IN THE
COMMITTEE. HOW MANY TIMES I WENT
TO HER ANALYSIS. AND FELT LIKE I
BETTER UNDERSTOOD THE ISSUE AND
OF COURSE IT'S ALWAYS NICE WHEN
SOMEONE PUTS IN THERE ARE REALLY
GOOD QUESTION THAT YOU CAN ASK.
AND CAROLINE WAS WAS AWESOME AT
THAT- NOW SHE'S HAD A VERY LONG
AND SUCCESSFUL CAREER IN
EDUCATION POLICY. THAT SHE
STARTED WORKING IN THE OFFICE OF
THE GOVERNOR. THEN TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS WELL AS
A FOUNDATION CONSORTIUM. A
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP
CHARGED WITH ESTABLISHING ELLIE
AS AS SCHOOLING TO HEALTH
PROVIDERS. BEFORE JOINING OUR
OFFICES THE POLICY CAROLINE
WORKED AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AS A
FISCAL SERVICES CONSULTANT. AND
PRIOR TO THAT SHE SERVED AS A
SENIOR FISCAL POLICY ANALYST FOR
THE SECRETARY OF EDUCATION WHERE
SHE ANALYZE K. THROUGH TWELVE
AND HIGHER EDUCATION FISCAL
LEGISLATION POLICY PROPOSALS.
AND PROGRAM REFORMS. IN ALL
CAROLINE HAS TWENTY YEARS OF X.
EXPERIENCE IN EDUCATION
LEGISLATION AND FISCAL POLICY
AND SHE HAS MADE INCREDIBLE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR CAUCUS AND
TO THE LEGISLATURE AS A WHOLE.
CAROLINE IS LOOKING FORWARD IN
HER RETIREMENT TO SPEND MORE
TIME WITH HER FAMILY INCLUDING
HER HUSBAND DAVE SON SAMUEL AND
DAUGHTER MEGAN. PLEASE JOIN ME
COLLEAGUES AND WISHING HER A
LONG HAPPY AND FULFILLING
RETIREMENT.
MR MCCARTY OR ALSO
RECOMMENDS THANK YOU I WANT TO
ADD ON TO MR GALLAGHER'S
COMMENTS. AND- CAROLINE. I HOPE
SHE LISTENS THE PERSON. CAROLINE
YES SO I JUST WANT TO ALSO NOTE
THAT- OF COURSE WE HAVE A
BIPARTISAN PROCESS WITH OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF THERE AND
WHETHER YOU'RE THE REPUBLICAN
CONSULTING THE DEMOCRATS I JUST
WANTED TO SAY THAT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH YOU THE
PAST FEW YEARS- THE ALWAYS
BROUGHT UP GOOD QUESTIONS IN
GOOD ISSUES FOR THE BETTERMENT
OF CALIFORNIA AND OUR STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE AND JUST
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR SERVICE
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE AND THE SUBCOMMITTEE THAT WE
SERVED ON. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
RECONSIDERATION ITEMS ON
RECONSIDERATION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE ITEMS TWO AND THREE
PASS AND RETAIN. WE ARE MOVING
THE SENATE THIRD READING. FILE
ITEMS FOUR AND FIVE PASS AND
RETAIN. WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
. FILE ITEM SIX DOCTOR WEBER HAS
AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX. SB TWO FORTY
FIVE FOR THEPURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS COURT AGREED WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL TWO FORTY
FIVE WITH A MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER. DR WEBER ON THE
AMENDMENTS. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO SENATE
BILL TWO FORTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR LENA GONZALEZ. THESE
AMENDMENTS CONTAIN CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE TO BETTER ENABLE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL BY
THE ADMINISTRATION THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS TO SB TWO
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU DR WEBER
MR FLOOR FOR PURPOSE SIR WE WILL
HOLD THEM STILL SYNONYMOUS
ASTRONOMICAL. MR FLOORS
REQUESTING A ROLL CALL VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS WITH THAT. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. MAJORITY PRESIDENT VOTING IS
THE THRESHOLD ON THE AMENDMENTS. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
THE CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY SEVEN KNOWS
FOURTEEN THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
BILLS OUT TO PRINT. AND BACK ON
FILE.
MEMBERS BEFORE WE MOVED TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. A
REMINDER THAT FRIDAY FEBRUARY
EIGHTEENTH IS THE LAST DAY FOR
BILLS TO BE INTRODUCED. I'D ALSO
LIKE TO KNOW THEIR THREE BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE MEETINGS TODAY
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE TWO ON
EDUCATION FINANCE WILL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT. IN ROOM. FOUR FOUR
FOUR. BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ONE
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WILL MEET AT TWO THIRTY PM. IN
ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX. BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE FIVE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
. WE'LL MEET AT TWO THIRTY PM IN
ROOM. FOUR THIRTY SEVEN. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
I'D ASK THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS. OR TAKE ANY
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
AT THIS TIME. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE GREEN
CARPET AT THIS TIME MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WHERE THE GERMANS IN
MEMORY.
MEMBERS WE ARE TO GERMAN
TO MEMORY AND ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE TAKE YUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF OF THE FLOOR. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS FOR GREATER PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY. MS CARILLO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
HONOR THE MEMORY OF FRANCISCO
FRANCO DAVID LEE MISS A PROUD
HUSBAND FATHER GRANDFATHER GREAT
GRANDFATHER FORMER EAST LA
RESIDENT AND WENT ON TO SERVE AN
ILLUSTRIOUS FORTY YEAR CAEER IN
L. A. UST AS A MUSIC TEACHER.
MISTER LOOMIS WAS ACTUALLY MY
ORCHESTRA AND MY AT T. TEACHER
WHEN I WAS IN SEVENTH AND EIGHTH
GRADE IT ALSO ELIMINATES SCHOOL
IN MY DISTRICT. AND WHILE IT'S
BEEN DECADES I'M THANKFUL FOR
HIS GUIDANCE AND HIS MENTORSHIP
. MISTER LOOMIS WAS BORN IN
DALLAS TEXAS IN NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE. AND PASSED AWAY IN-NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR HIS MOTHER
AND FATHER PREACHED IN CHURCHES
IN TEXAS MICHIGAN IN CALIFORNIA
AND IT WITHIN THE CHURCH WHERE
HE FOUND HIS LIFE LONG LOVE OF
MUSIC. MUSIC BECAME THE
CORNERSTONE OF HIS LIFE. AND IT
WAS BECAUSE OF HIS MUSIC TEACHER
THAT HE DISCOVERED THE FRENCH
HORN. WITH WHICH HE PERFORMED AT
PARADES CONCERTS SCHOOL PLAYS.
AND THAT WOULD LEAD HIM TO A
CAREER WITH THE LOS ANGELES
PHILHARMONIC. MUCH LIKE MANY
YOUNG PEOPLE FROM MY COMMUNITY
MR LIMA STUDIED MUSIC AT EAST LA
COLLEGE AND CAL STATE LA. AND
RECEIVED A MASTER'S IN MUSIC
EDUCATION. HE LOVED MUSIC HE
LEARNED TO PLAY EVERY INSTRUMENT
AVAILABLE TO HIM AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY. HE LOVED TO SHARE
IN THAT GIFT. TO LEARN TO READ
AND WRITE MUSIC IS TO KNOW A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT LANGUAGE.
HE TAUGHT ALL HIS STUDENTS THAT
. NO MATTER WHAT IT NECESSITY
BACKGROUND OR LANGUAGE YOU
SPOKE. THE NOTES ON A MUSIC
SHEET WERE LANGUAGE WE ALL
UNDERSTOOD. MANY OF HIS STUDENTS
WENT ON TO BECOME MUSIC TEACHERS
AND PROFESSIONAL MUSICIANS
THEMSELVES PLAN IDEOLOGY AND
JAZZ BANDS AND CLASSICAL MUSIC
SYMPHONY. I WANT TO SHARE A
PERSONAL STORY ABOUT MR LIMITS
IN THE POWER OF A GREAT TEACHER
. WHEN I WAS IN SEVENTH GRADE IS
WHEN I LEARNED THAT I WAS
UNDOCUMENTED. MISTER LIMITS
FOUND ME CRYING IN THE CORNER OF
A MUSIC CLASS. MY MOTHER HAS
SHARED THAT WE NEEDED TO LEAVE
THE COUNTRY AND RETURNED TO US
ABOUT. THE COUNTRY HAD FINALLY
ENDED. ITS BLOODY CIVIL WAR AND
HAD SIGNED A PEACE AGREEMENT. I
WAS SAD TO LEAVE MY FRIENDS MY
SCHOOL AND MY VIOLIN BEHIND. I
WAS FORTUNATE THAT I HAD A
PATHWAY TO RESIDENCY AND WAS
ABLE TO RETURN TO THAT MUSIC
ROOM IN EL SERENO. THE BACK WITH
MY FRIENDS. LAUGH AT SILLY
THINGS AND BE A CHILD AGAIN.
MISTER LIMITS WAS THERE FOR ME.
AND ONE OF THE MOST DIFFICULT
TIMES OF MY YOUNG LIFE. HE RE
FOCUS MY ENERGIES TAMI TO LEAN
INTO MUSIC. TO CONTINUE PLAYING
TO BE PROUD OF WHO I WAS WHERE I
CAME FROM. AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
PERSEVERANCE. IT IS BECAUSE OF
HIM HIS BELIEF IN ME THAT I
COULD PLAN FOR A FEW MORE YEARS
AT ROOSEVELT HIGH SCHOOL IN
BOYLE HEIGHTS. EVERY TIME I HEAR
THE TUNING OF STRINGS. I AM
REMINDED OF THE INNOCENCE OF
THAT TIME. THE ONLY WAY THAT I
CAN DESCRIBE THE POWER MISTER
LOOMIS AND THEREFORE THE POWER
OF A GREAT TEACHER. IS THE QUOTE
MANTELLO. PEOPLE WILL FORGET
WHAT YOU SAY PEOPLE WILL FORGET
WHAT YOU DID. BUT PEOPLE WILL
NEVER FORGET HOW YOU MADE THEM
FEEL. I DON'T REMEMBER MUCH
ABOUT SEVENTH GRADE HER EIGHTH
GRADE. BUT I REMEMBER THAT MR
LEE MISS MADE ME FEEL SAFE. LIKE
I BELONGED THAT I HAD VALUE.
THAT I HAD A TALENT THAT NO ONE
CAN EVER TAKE AWAY. NO MATTER
WHAT MY LEGAL STATUS WAS. THAT
FEELING. MADE THE BIGGEST IMPACT
IN MY LIFE. HI THERE SAY IT IS
ONE OF THE MANY CORNERSTONES IN
MY LIFE THAT ALLOWS ME TO BE
HERE TODAY. MISTER LIMITED
SURVIVED BY HIS MOTHER SIBLINGS
HIS THREE CHILDREN. THREE
GRANDCHILDREN AND A GREAT
GRANDDAUGHTER. HIS LEGACY IS
FELT AMONG THE HEARTS OF
STUDENTS ACROSS OUR GOLDEN STATE
. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES I ASKED
THAT WE HAD DURING THE LIFE OF
MR FRANKLY MISS AN INCREDIBLE
TEACHER AND FRIEND. HIS MEMORY
BE A BLESSING AND MAY HIS GENTLE
DEMEANOR HIS LAUGHTER AND HIS
MANY MUSIC TALENTS ECHO ACROSS
THE HEAVENS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS CARILLO. VOEPEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. MISTER
SPEAKER. MEMBERS IT IS WITH A
HEAVY HEART THAT I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF PASTOR
HAROLD BROWN I PERSONALLY NEW
PASTOR BROWN THROUGH HIS WORK
WITH THE EAST COUNTY
TRANSITIONAL LIVING CENTER. NOW
IN MY DISTRICT THAT MEANS YOU'RE
HELPING THE HOMELESS THE USER.
CASTAWAY PEOPLE THE PASTOR BROWN
BROUGHT BACK INTO THE WORLD.
AFTER GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL HE
SERVED IN THE UNITED STATES ARMY
FROM. NINETEEN EIGHTY TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX NOW THAT'S
WHERE THINGS WENT WRONG FOR HIM. I'M A HEAVY DUTY COMBAT
VETERAN. SO I BARELY MADE THE
TRANSITION FROM THE MILITARY TO
CIVILIAN LIFE BARELY AND MY WIFE
IS NOT EVEN SURE I DID IT TODAY
OKAY. PASTOR BROWN WENT OFF THE
RAILS. WITH PASTOR BROWN FINALLY
RETURNED TO SAN DIEGO RETURNED
AS A BROKEN MAN AND ADDICTED TO
ALCOHOL AND WHAT EVER ELSE
HOWEVER WHEN HE ENTERED THE SAN
DIEGO RESCUE MISSION PROGRAM HE
WAS SAVED BY THE GRACE OF JESUS
CHRIST AND FREED FROM HIS
ADDICTION HE CASTED OFF HE LATER
BECAME AN EMPLOYEE OF THE RESCUE
MISSION AND GRADUALLY WORKED HIS
WAY UP TO FACILITY DIRECTOR HE
STARTED AT THE BOTTOM HE WAS
JUST A HOMELESS GUY. STARTING
FROM THE BOTTOM. IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE PASTOR BROWN
MARRIAGES WIFE. JACKIE AND THEY
RAISE FOUR CHILDREN TOGETHER A
FEW YEARS LATER IN TWO THOUSAND
ONE HERALD LEFT THE MISSION AND
ENTERED A PASTORAL TRAINING
PROGRAM WITH THE SAN DIEGO
SOUTHERN BAPTIST ASSOCIATION
WHERE HE LATER BECAME THAT
ADORNED ORDAINED MINISTER. AN
ADORNED. AFTER RECEIVING HIS
DEGREE IN DIVINITY FROM ALAMEDA
UNIVERSITY IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
HE WAS NAMED SENIOR PASTOR OF
CHRISTIAN FELLOWSHIP OF ALCOHOL
THE FOLLOWING YEAR PASTOR BROWN
BECAME THE FOUNDING CEO OF EAST
COUNTY TRANSITIONAL LIVING
CENTER HELPING THOUSANDS OF
HOMELESS FILLERS WORK WITH THESE
COUNTY TRANSITIONAL LIVING
CENTER HE HAS LED A SMALL
DEDICATED. STAFF AND I WOULD
LIKE TO PUT IN OVERWORKED IN
ASSISTING THOUSANDS OF MEN WOMEN
AND CHILDREN WHO HAVE COME TO
THEM LOOKING FOR HOPE DIGNITY
AND PURPOSE TO FIND A NEW
QUALITY OF LIFE THROUGH A
FOUNDATION IN CHRIST JUST SAYS
HE DID GOING THROUGH THE RINGER
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE PASTOR
HAROLD BROWN WILL BE MISSED BY
ALL THAT KNEW HIM IN OUR
COMMUNITY IS FOREVER THANKFUL
FOR THE WORK IS DONE THE WHOLE
P. INSPIRED AND THOUSANDS. AND
HIS DETERMINATION TO HELPING
THOSE WHO NEED IT MOST MAY HE
READ AS MPS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MR VOEPEL
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
OF THE DESERT PRINT IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY. FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH
CHECK IN SESSION. WEDNESDAY
FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH CHECK IN
SESSION THURSDAY FEBRUARY
SEVENTEENTH CHECK IN SESSION
FRIDAY. EIGHTEENTH A FOUR
SESSION IS AT NINE AM. ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
TO RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUE SEEING INTERNAL FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN. MR LEE
MOVES MISS VALID THERE'S SECONDS
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL FRIDAY FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH
AT NINE AM. WE ARE TURN.